it's time to hit the track then as we
embark upon another thrilling round of
formula one racing here at imola welcome
to the amelia romania grand prix
one lap of himmler anti-clockwise of
course unlike most formula one circuits
will take our drivers around 3.1 miles
of track 19 turns nine right handers and
10 to the left drivers will need to be
precise at the hairpin at turn seven
given the subsequent uphill section
without a good exit from that corner
they'll lose a lot of time on that
stretch
so with the race not far away from
starting here's what today's grid
rundown looks like lewis hamilton lines
up on pole position and a very happy
carlos science will start second
considering the rest of the grid we have
perez leclair
george russell and verstappen
sonoda
fernando alonso and pierre gasly
mick schumacher ocon
kevin magnussen and bottas
latifi norris
daniel ricardo and lance stroll
albom and sebastian vettel starts from
the back of the grid
now it's almost time for lights out so
let's go down to the track
natalie pinkham joins me once again in
the commentary box it's fantastic to
have you with us today i'm curious
though how do you think the drivers stop
those pre-race nerves from becoming
overwhelming when you're lining up on
the grid well i imagine they'll be
starting to feel the adrenaline as they
anticipate the rundown into turn one a
bit like preparing to go into battle the
unknown situation will bring nerves but
that's a good thing it'll keep them
focused on the moment and on their
surroundings as we build towards the
start of the grand prix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we've got a lot of spare energy okay
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
that's p3 who is the podium position
well done
ah
okay drs is now available
you're in the top 10 now keep it up
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
nice work mate that brings you up a
place
[Music]
[Music]
good job that was the fastest lap of the
race so far
so
oh
[Music]
bruh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
it was a magnificent race and a drive
right out of the top drawer to take the
win for red bull today
so natalie what do you think help them
deliver this result rain always has the
potential to liven up a race and mix up
the order and they've taken full
advantage of that to claim the victory
today it's a bit of a lottery when the
conditions are like this but they've
managed to stay on the circuit and have
come out on top
[Applause]
red bull put up an outstanding fight for
the front position today and it's great
to see it paid off for them they do so
much for the sports that you can't help
but be delighted by today's race win
foreign
[Applause]